and meanwhile scientists hope they have
a huge treasure trove of data from
yesterday's Eclipse including amateur
photos like all of these providing new
insight into our solar system they're
getting it help from teams of citizen
scientists spread out along the path of
totality and Adriana Diaz is in
Carbondale Illinois where there was a
large contingent of these budding
stargazers Adriana good morning good
morning yesterday this campus was full
of volunteer scientists and their
telescopes they were working as NASA's
citizen army on a mission to collect as
much data as possible on the Eclipse and
that they did together they produced
more than 4,000 images an astronomical
amount that's good
did we check this bounce - as the day
wore on anticipation grew for the
sublime spectacle that would last just 2
minutes and 27 seconds I think we just
need to tilt this away from the Sun and
put our solar lens on so the camera
doesn't get fried but these teenagers
cosmic journey started much earlier
we're ten hours away so it's quite a
drive but it's definitely worth it to
come and get to see something so amazing
Reba Doucet Elliott iwon and Alexis
Cochran are from a Native American
reservation school in northern Montana
they took a road trip with their science
teacher
Janet Jorgenson to the abandoned town of
JM Wyoming to watch and study the
Eclipse it's just an amazing opportunity
for the kids because this is real life
science and it helps them be exposed to
what kind of opportunities there might
be in the future these students are one
of 68 teams nationwide who participated
in an amateur science experiment called
citizen Kate volunteers with an
extraordinary mission we're trying to
get pictures of the solar clip so we can
study the corona which is the light that
comes on the edges they're like solar
flares and stuff that come off the Sun
you can really only study when there's
an eclipse we can follow the shadow of
the Moon as it crosses the United States
and take data sequentially sort of like
in a little relay race Matt Penn is the
project's director his team at Tucson
National Solar Observatory provided the
volunteers with equipment and
instructions for the astronomical
undertaking if the network works
perfectly we'll get 30 tie
the data of previous studies even if we
have 50% participation we'll get 10
times the amount of data so it's going
to be a big improvement
either way oh when the eclipse began
volunteers just had to press go and the
computer did the rest here in Carbondale
Illinois they captured out-of-this-world
images like this so-called diamond ring
effect oh you could see you could see
back in Wyoming look how dark it getting
when the moment finally arrived darkness
descended on the town of JM look at the
way the light comes off the Sun there
and the site they've been waiting for
revealed itself a total solar eclipse
before they knew it it was over but for
these kids from a remote Native American
reservation minutes and 27 seconds let's
see one we're a lifetime it's just
something you don't forget it
the citizens scientists will be able to
keep the equipment they were given the
director of the project said he hopes
that will inspire them to stay engaged
in astronomy and perhaps even consider
careers as scientists Margaret
Adriana did you go a clip shopping
looking at your dress yeah believe it or
not I owned this before
no you know you it is perfect though I
gotta say it lived in China
oh really we were all commenting on it
it looks great it is a perfect knot but
you know you're just talking about the
emotional reaction
you know Instagram told us more than 50
million people were on during the
Eclipse that's more than the Superbowl
so bright so many people just trying to
capture the moment and they did it in
the old days it was just little pockets
of people who would see it we hear
stories so many yesterday which I
thought was nice it was